the heart is a muscular organ with four  chambers  blood collects in the hearts to upper  chambers or atria before filling the two  lower chambers or ventricles when the  ventricles contract blood in the right  ventricle is pumped to the lungs and  blood in the left ventricle is pumped to  the rest of the body the heart has a  natural pacemaker called the sinoatrial  node or SA node the pacemaker controls  the heart rate by precisely determining  when the muscles of the atria and  ventricles contract the electrical  signal produced by the SA node reaches  the ventricles through a narrow pathway  that includes the so called AV node and  bundle branches taken together these  pathways are referred to as the  conduction system of the heart